first on there he is on CBS this morning
hi Derrick Jones also notice be nice I
am soaked Saturday night Derrick I
literally got out of my bed
and was just dancing around the room in
my t-shirt it was so much fun people
started calling why don't we have video
of that I started calling through they
go we're watching we're watching so
where did this idea come from Derrick
and how do you decide the setlist it was
so great Saturday night so I was at I
was at home I'm self isolating so it's
just sitting here and I realize outside
of just missing my family that the other
most important thing to me was the crowd
at DJing for people and I woke up at 4
o'clock in the morning and just decided
I wanted to throw a party and and I was
supposed to just leave for my friends
you know just a few friends on Instagram
and then it turned into and I was
literally just playing music for my
laptop and the next day I hooked up the
turntables and then I noticed that the
crowd started to grow John Legend is in
there and you know I called Dave
Chappelle up and he jumped there live
and then the next day jail occasion
Drake here arrived and then that
Saturday night party was like everything
it was like everyone was there I know
what surprised you the most you seem to
get very excited when you said Mark
Zuckerberg is joined you could see how
surprised that you seemed to get a big
kick out of that I thought that was kind
of funny too but Mark Zuckerberg likes
music he likes to play no I love that
photo my job then it was just exciting
that the part that that touched me the
most was you know I put in a call to see
if I could get you know two former first
lady in there and you know I wasn't sure
in the moment that she popped in I just
froze and it's not
before I just froze like I don't know
what the play the music faded and I was
like oh I know what she loves she loves
beyoncé let's later when you look when
you look down you see there's a hundred
and sixty thousand people in the room
what are you thinking I mean I'm like
wow this is like pretty much the
equivalent of like two stadiums of
people just listening to music and at
that point you ask the question early
about places I don't have a playlist I
literally just play what feels good you
know I wanted people to feel that I want
their spirits to be lifted through music
one you know just one song at a time
yeah it was definitely happening that's
why you had a hundred sixty thousand
tuned in but what do you think it is
about music that that people need right
now I think I mean music has always been
the greatest see you know like you know
you can just feel good you know no
matter what your problems are you put on
a good tune and it just takes you away
and I was trying to like do that through
music you know and also what was what
was great it was that that people the
other component was that people were in
a chat room and the beauty of it was it
initially started with my friends all
pretending that they were inside of a
club like hey we'll pack of a jump in
like hey I'll meet you at the bar let
this person in the whole experience was
fun it wasn't just them just the music
it was just the experiencing everyone
just kind of like escaping you know
what's going on today just for a few
hours I know and you are so used to
playing to large crowds how different
was it because you're alone too when
you're playing the music was it a weird
feeling for you to I mean I guess the
weird part was that my neighbors were
complaining no nice you were performing
a public service Derek that's how I look
at it and part of the fun too was
watching you change your hats throughout
the evening guys you go time for a
change
keep doing this then do you have enough
hatch to go along did your attorneys
question how doing it I mean I was going
to take a break but you know since
everyone's saying
daily thing and you kind of influence me
so I think I'm gonna just continue doing
as those people you know I read the
comments and people are saying some
incredible things and now how the music
is uplifting experience and we all feel
so connected in in that moment through
the chat rooms you know interview you
know you what time are you going on
tonight today you know what I'm gonna
set a time right now let's say 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time
let's do it
Heidi nice thanks you